>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nick Brown: Good evening,
ladies and gentlemen,
and welcome to the
Library of Congress.
My name is Nicholas Brown,
and I work in the Office
of Special Events
and Public Programs.
On behalf of the
librarians' office,
thank you for being here.
We are working tonight with our
colleagues in the Law Library
of Congress and also in
the European division
to commemorate the 500th
anniversary of the Reformation.
The Library has an ongoing
display entitled Martin Luther
as Priest, Heretic, and
Outlaw: The Reformation at 500,
which is on display in the
Thomas Jefferson Building
through January 1st, and
today, we are very privileged
to have Brad Gregory with us.
He is a professor at the
University of Notre Dame,
and he is the author of Rebel in
the Ranks, which is right here,
and he's going to be lecturing
and discussing Martin Luther's
legacy and also the legacy
of the Reformation on culture
since this all took
place 500 years ago.
Professor Gregory is the
author of multiple books,
including Salvation at
Stake: Christian Martyrdom
in Early Modern Europe, and
also The Unintended Reformation:
How a Religious Revolution
Secularized Society.
He's one of the leading
scholars on the Reformation
and also religion of that
period in the United States,
so it's a great honor
to have him here with us
at the Library of
Congress tonight.
A few housekeeping
notes to share
with you about the evening.
The discussion will be about
45 minutes, plus Q and A
in this room, at which
point you'll be invited
to view a very special treasures
display from the Law Library
of Congress, which my colleague
Margaret Wood will discuss
in a few moments.
This was curated by Nathan Dorn,
who is the rare books curator
for the Law Library's
collections.
You can check out the
Law Library's resources
and collections online
at loc.gov/law.
We also invite you to live tweet
at any time during this event
in order to help us promote the
fact that the Library is, one,
having free lectures, which
is really great, and also,
to share your impressions of
Professor Gregory's discussion,
and we're using the
hashtag Reformation500.
Also, at the conclusion
of the talk,
you will have the opportunity
to get a book signed
if you so choose.
The Library's gift shop has
generously joined us this
evening to offer books on
sale at a discounted rate
of 22 dollars, and Professor
Gregory will be available
to sign at the conclusion of the
program, and then if you would
like to see the display that
is upstairs, the Martin Luther
as Priest, Heretic, and Outlaw
display, we'll gather as a group
and go together whenever
you're ready, because it's
in a closed portion of the
building, so we're going to have
to go there en masse and
be guided, so that's going
to be exciting, and you
can also see the oldest map
of the United States printed in
the United States and created
by a United States citizen from
1784, which is kind of cool.
Without further ado,
I'm going to welcome
up my colleague Margaret,
who will give us a brief
introduction to the rare books
over here, and then we'll turn
it over to Professor Gregory.
Thank you.
>> Margaret Wood:
Thank you, Nicholas.
I'm Margaret Wood, and I'm
a public services library
with the Law Library
of Congress.
>> Nick Brown: We need you on
the microphone so we can hear.
Sorry.
>> Margaret Wood: Oh, sorry.
Okay.
>> Nick Brown: Thanks
>> Margaret Wood:
Good to meet you.
All right, I hate not to be
able to point to the books.
I am a public services librarian
with the Law Library
of Congress.
My colleague Nathan Dorn,
who is the rare book curator,
went ahead and put together
the exhibit for this evening.
It includes a number
of beautiful items
and also very interesting items
from the Law Library's
rare book collection.
It begins in 1502
with Pope Leo's bull,
which says to Martin
Luther "recant,"
which apparently
doesn't work out.
In 1521, as I understand it,
Martin Luther burned some
of his canon law books
as a symbolic protest,
and we have a beautiful
early 16th century collection
of canon law in recognition
of that event.
Following that, there are
several texts that were written
by evangelicals, some who may
or may not have had
a legal background,
but they were going ahead
and reworking criminal law,
family law, and municipal law.
One of my favorites in that
area is actually a lovely,
very short 1534 religious law
book that was put together
for the Duke of Wartenburg.
Then we've got Henry the
8th's 1534 "begone, pope."
He gets rid of Peter's pence
and therefore cuts off money,
and the end of the exhibit
are actually three items
from the United States.
The first is 1630.
It's John Cotton's
draft for the laws
of Massachusetts Bay colony,
based on the penitook.
They were not adopted, but
New Hampshire looks to them,
and then we have William
Penn's charter and a copy
of the 1786 Virginia
Thomas Jefferson Law
and Religious Freedom.
I invite you to look
at these items.
You may take photographs as
long as there's no flash,
and if you'd like me to turn the
pages after, please feel free,
and any questions about
rare book material
in the Law Library, you
can just, as Nicholas said,
go to our website,
contact the library,
and we can put you
in touch with Nathan.
Thank you.
>> Nick Brown: Professor
Greg, yeah.
>> Brad Gregory: Okay.
Thank you very much.
Quite a difference in height
between Margaret and myself,
so they'll adjust
the height here.
Thanks very much, Nicholas,
for the introduction before.
Thanks to all of you
for coming this evening.
It's wonderful to see you here.
It's a great honor for me to
be in our nation's capital
and at the Library of Congress
delivering this lecture in honor
of and commemorating the 500th
anniversary of the Reformation
as part of the ongoing series of
lectures and other events here
at the Library of Congress
under the rubric The Reformation
at 500, and please, if
you're going to live tweet,
only positive comments,
please, and thank you very much.
Okay. My talk this evening
is going to make an argument
with two main components.
First, the Reformation
was not only important
in the 16th century,
but remained essential
for understanding our world
today, regardless of whether
or not you're a Protestant
or even a religious believer,
and secondly, the Reformation's
influence today is by
and large indirect and
the opposite of what any
of the major reformers
of the 16th century,
including Martin Luther,
wanted their reform
of western Christendom to
achieve, for the long-term,
unintended, and yet
undeniable overriding outcome
of the Reformation has
been the secularization
of western society.
Western modernity, in its
dominant institutions, ideas,
values, and practices,
including in the United States,
is not an outgrowth of
the Reformation in any
of its 16th century expressions.
It's rather a reaction
against the Reformation era
and the way it's
doctrinal disagreements
and its concrete conflicts made
Christianity into a problem
to which modernity has
been the response in ways
that have fostered
secularization.
My talk this evening
gives a glimpse
of the book that's rather
shamelessly displayed on
and off here on both sides
of me, Rebel in the Ranks:
Martin Luther, the
Reformation, and the Conflicts
that Continue to
Shape our World.
My argument concerns the
historical consequences
of the Reformation
era, not which, if any,
among the Christian traditions
that emerged from it is true
or mistaken, right or
wrong, the criteria
for assessing these
issues, and so forth.
I've structured my
talk as a play,
a play in four acts preceded
by a prelude which parallel --
what a coincidence -- the
four chapters of my book.
My talk, like my book, starts
small and expands outward
in its subject matter,
its time frames,
and its geographical range.
It moves from late
medieval Christianity
to one Augustinian friar, a
German movement, a European era,
and western modernity
as a whole.
So here we go.
Prelude. Christianity
as more than religion.
Today, religion is
your individual choice,
including the option not
to be religious at all.
It's considered a distinct
area of life among others,
separate from your career,
professional relationships,
recreational activities,
consumer behavior, and so on.
Neither of these things was
true in the early 16th century.
Leaving aside Europe's
tiny percentage of Jews,
religion was not a matter of
choice, nor was it separate
from the rest of life.
You became a Christian
through the taken for granted,
centuries-old ritual
of infant baptism,
and religion was not hived
off from the rest of life.
It didn't stand apart
from exercising power
or administering
justice, but was meant
to inform politics and law.
Christianity wasn't
segregated from buying
and selling goods
or pursuing profit.
Its teachings sought
to circumscribe economic
transactions
and to restrain greed.
Education was imbued
with Christian ideas,
from teaching ABCs in
humble primary schools
through instruction in one of
Europe's 60 or so universities.
Social relationships and gender
expectations as well as public
and private morality were
conceived in Christian terms.
Faith was meant to influence not
only how Christians worshipped
and prayed, but also how
they ruled and worked,
bought and sold,
taught and learned, --
-- and understood their lives.
In short, religion
was about much more
than what we usually
mean by religion.
Now, none of this implies that
many people behaved like saints.
Far from it.
The Reformation sought
to address this problem,
although it wasn't its
leader's main concern.
Conscientious Christians
had been aware
of the problems long before
Martin Luther appeared
on the scene.
Sinful shortcomings in
the church and the lives
of its members, including
its clerical leaders,
affected everything else because
religion was so intertwined
with the rest of life.
For centuries before
the Reformation,
the gap between Christian ideals
and lived realities was lamented
by men and women who were
saintly and sought reforms,
say Bernard of Clairvaux
in the 12th century,
or Catherine of Siena
in the 14th.
Without question, there
were perceived problems
in the late medieval church,
including the western schism,
conflicts over authority,
worldly renaissance popes
and cardinals, greedy
members of the clergy,
and ill-informed lay people,
so no wonder there
was a Reformation,
the traditional explanation
went,
considering papal decadence,
the church's corruption,
and lay superstition.
Luther saved the day by
rediscovering the gospel.
Yet decades of scholarship
have corrected this picture
with massive evidence
about the vitality
of late medieval Christianity,
from lay bible reading
in the vernacular to the
voluntary lay support
of parish churches
and religious orders,
to enthusiastic lay
participation
in confraternities,
and much more.
In fact, more 15th century
Christians were probably more
self-consciously devout
than their predecessors
in any proceeding century.
The Reformation emerged as much
out of religious commitment
as a reaction against the
church's shortcomings.
Indeed, these two
things went together.
People tend to want to reform
things that they care about.
Yet the fact that religion
wasn't something separate
from other areas of
life is more fundamental
for explaining the long-term
impact of the Reformation
and how our present contrasts
with its leaders most
basic objectives.
It wasn't something you
could step away from
or decide you didn't
want to affect you.
You didn't have to be devout,
but you couldn't avoid living
in a Christian society.
Religion was never
just about religion.
It influenced everything
else, for better or worse,
so because religion was
connected to everything else,
changes in religion would
affect everything else,
and the Reformation
brought changes
in Latin Christianity unlike
anything else in the Middle Ages
in its geographical
scope, its staying power,
and its transformative
influence.
The Reformation affected
not only religion
but also everything related to
religion in the 16th century --
in other words, just about
every area of human life.
The Reformation would be the
reformation of everything.
This gets us a step closer
to why the Reformation
still matters today.
Changes in religion
and disagreements
about Christianity
had consequences
that went far beyond religion
as we usually think about it,
and those changes and
those disagreements started
with an Augustinian friar and
university professor anxious
about his own salvation.
Act one, Martin Luther:
Reluctant Rebel.
Martin Luther is enormously
interesting in his own right,
and more has been
written about him
than any other single person
except Jesus of Nazareth,
but explaining why the
Reformation still matters
regardless of our own
beliefs doesn't depend
on whether we find
Luther fascinating,
like his theology,
or agree with him.
He matters historically because
of what he set in motion,
the basis on which he did so,
and how transformative
both have been.
Now I assume that many of you
are familiar with the basics
of Luther's remarkable story,
between the fall of 1517
and the spring of 1521, so I'm
only going to say a few things
about it this evening, and even
if you aren't familiar with it,
well, the remedy for that,
of course, is to buy my book,
Rebel in the Ranks, because
chapter one is all about that.
In October of 1517, almost
no one had even heard
of Martin Luther
outside of a few towns
and Augustinian friaries
in central Germany.
Three a half years later,
he had condemned the papacy,
defied the emperor, and become
Europe's most famous man,
as well as its most published
author since the invention
of the printing press
in the 1450s.
The Reformation is even more
astonishing because no one
in 1517 could have
anticipated it.
No one could have
guessed it would start
in a forgettable town of
about 2,000 people in Saxony,
and even less could anyone
have imagined that the actions
of an ultra-devout,
ultra-conscientious
university professor
and friar would be behind it.
If you'd asked those who knew
Luther what his future might
hold in the summer of 1517,
they probably would have
predicted a successful academic
career in the church.
Thousands of friars had
pursued such careers
since the 13th century,
when universities first
began to take hold.
They continued to
do so in the 1510s,
and Luther had made an
impressive start on the same.
Luther's career as an
Augustinian from 1506
to the summer of 1517
was marked by success,
with no observable signs
of opposition or rebellion.
On the contrary,
Luther was diligent
and obedient to a fault.
He was ordained a priest
and celebrated his
first mass in 1507.
He showed himself eager
for religious life,
spiritually intense,
intellectually gifted,
and interested in scripture.
As far as could be observed,
he was a thriving Augustinian
professor of theology
in his early 30s, teaching
at a new university
in the provincial German
town of Wittenberg,
yet not all was as it seemed.
What really mattered in early
1517 remained as invisible
to almost everyone as
it had been for years.
Inside, Luther was
wracked with anxiety.
He was tormented nearly
to the point of despair
because of his life
as an Augustinian
and the exacting ways
in which he sought
to live up to its demands.
Luther's interior torments
were the religious roots
of the Reformation.
He wasn't a rebel seeking
to undermine the church,
nor did he aspire to
start one of his own.
The very notion would
have seemed absurd to him.
Luther's own anxiety,
intense as it was,
wouldn't in itself have
produced the Reformation.
It began because Luther acted
on his anxiety in relationship
to those who pushed
back against him.
Beginning in late 1517,
those who objected
to what Luther was saying
and how he was saying it
started a back and forth series
of interactions through which
Luther's ideas became bolder
and clearer.
Critically, those ideas
became widely known
through correspondence,
oral communication,
and especially through print.
The beginning of the Reformation
depended on publicity by
and resistance to Martin Luther.
Through his reactions to that
resistance and his embrace
of the fame that seemed
to come out of nowhere,
he became a reluctant rebel.
I'm going to mention just a few
major stages in that process.
If the Ninety-Five Theses were
actually posted on the door
of Wittenberg's Castle Church
500 years ago, the event was
about as thrilling
as a professor today
posting an announcement
to the departmental
bulletin board.
Seriously deflating, but true.
But the printing
and the distribution
of the Ninety-Five Theses
was a difference maker,
as was the fact that Luther
sent them to Archbishop Albrecht
of Mainz, the most
powerful churchman
in the Holy Roman Empire.
Albrecht sent them on to
Rome, and in early 1518,
several fellow theologians
saw a connection in the theses
between Luther's criticism
of indulgence preachers
and papal authority.
This was a crucial
bridge that would lead
through in-person confrontations
and dozens of back
and forth polemical pamphlets
to mutual condemnations.
Luther innovated by publicizing
controversial religious matters
in vernacular print,
starting in March of 1518.
He repeatedly said he
would retract any views
about which he could be shown to
his satisfaction to be mistaken,
and increasingly, this had
to be demonstrated to him
on the basis of scripture.
This insistence on God's word
gave Luther what he needed
to reject papal authority.
For reasons that will
soon become clear,
this was his most consequential
move as a reformer,
the insistence on
scripture alone
as the self-sufficient basis
for Christian faith and life.
By the summer of
1520, a papal bull
of excommunication was
being prepared against him,
while he was writing and then
published the three hugely
influential treatises that
appeared later than year,
to the Christian Nobility
of the German Nation,
on the Babylonian Captivity
of the Church, right there.
Oh, not now.
That's my book, but in three
seconds, it'll come up again,
that treatise, the title page.
There it is.
And the Freedom of a Christian.
He responded to the
excommunication threat
by publicly burning the papal
bull and the church's canon law,
was excommunicated in
January of 1521, and in April,
refused to recant his views
in the iconic showdown
with Charles the Fifth
at the Diet of Worms.
"Hier stehe ich."
"Here I stand."
Then Frederick of
Saxony's men took him
into protective hiding --
-- in the Wartburg Castle for
the better part of a year,
where among other things, he
drafted his own translation
of the New Testament
into German.
Amazing stuff.
The story is all
the more astonishing
because it was so unlikely.
There's no understanding
the Reformation without it,
but it is not the history
of the Reformation.
Luther started the Reformation
without intending to,
but it very quickly
became a movement
that escaped his control,
and so we move on to act two,
The Early German Reformation:
A Fractious Movement.
It would be more accurate to say
that Luther never had control
of the Reformation than to say
he had it and then lost it.
His insistence on
scripture alone
as the sole final
authority for Christian faith
and life cleared away
long-standing obstacles
to reform within the established
church by creating a principle
and a position outside it.
Eventually, those Christians
who rejected Rome would
be called Protestants,
a term coined first in 1529.
As the 1520s would show, it was
easier to denounce the church
as corrupt and unbiblical than
to agree on what God's word said
and how it should be applied,
and because Christianity shaped
and was intended to influence
every area of human life,
the implications were enormous.
What did proper Christian
worship, sacraments,
and ministry look like, and who
had the authority to say so?
What now was the right
relationship between the church
and political authorities?
Did the freedom of a Christian
extend to social, political,
and economic concerns?
How could you tell whether
someone had the right
understanding of the gospel
or was really inspired
by the Holy Spirt?
Which prophecies about the
world's end were trustworthy?
The questions were
nearly endless.
So were the answers.
Those who rejected
Rome disagreed
about what God's word said and
so about what God's truth was,
so they disagreed about what
Christians should believe
and do.
By the time Luther returned from
the Wartburg Castle in March
of 1522, Andreas Karlstadt
disputed his downgrading
of the Book of James and his
views about the Old Testament,
Eucharistic practice,
the oral confession
of sins, and religious images.
Luther and Philip Melanchthon
disagreed with Huldrych Zwingli
and the latter's allies
about Christ's presence
in the Lord's Supper, a
dispute that inspired dozens
of hostile pamphlets
and culminated
in the dramatic face-to-face
non-resolution
of the Marburg Colloquy in 1529.
This became a crucial doctrinal
and thus also ecclesial
and social ground for the
distinction between Lutheranism
and Reform Protestantism.
Zwingli disagreed also
with his former colleagues,
such as Balthasar
Hubmaier and Conrad Grebel,
over the scriptural
basis for infant baptism,
with its enormous
ecclesiological implications.
This led to the origins of
Swiss Anabaptism by early 1525,
by which time the German
Peasants' War was raging,
with leaders such as Thomas
Muntzer completely rejecting
Luther's distinction between
the gospel on the one hand
and social, economic, and
political concerns on the other.
Withdrawing from dreams
of remaking society
after the Peasants' War,
Anabaptists disagreed
among themselves in a host
of doctrinally and therefore
socially divisive ways,
beginning already
in the late 1520s,
and all these disputes are in
addition to the disagreements
and the divisions between
these Christians and those
who remained in the
Roman church.
The Reformation began with
the forceful figure of Luther,
but regarding the Reformation as
him and rival ideas ad movements
as deviations is
just really a way
of saying one prefers Luther's
position over the others.
Many of his contemporaries
disagreed,
as do their respective
religious heirs, Mennonites
or Presbyterians, for example.
Luther's stance was based on his
principle about the authority
of scripture, ratified by
his persona experience.
Many others embraced the
principle, but rejected many
of Luther's claims
about God's word,
just as Luther rejected many of
the claims of the Roman church.
If everyone who rejected Rome
had agreed with Luther's claims
about the Bible,
not just the 1520s,
but the entire Reformation era
and, indeed, the last 500 years
of western history would have
played out very differently.
That is not what
happened, starting already
in Wittenberg in 1521.
This fact and its many
unintended consequences,
as they unfolded in the
1520s and during the rest
of the 16th century and
beyond, are critical
for understanding
the Reformation
and why it still matters.
Luther alone is a sure recipe
for misunderstanding
the Reformation,
however personally
inspiring the maxim might be
for those Christians who
love Luther's theology.
Already in the 1520s,
the Reformation radically
exceeded Luther's control
in ways that enraged him
and that reinforced his
apocalyptic expectations.
So the Reformation involved
disagreements among Protestants
no less than it predisposed
the reaction
of the Roman Catholic Church.
This started among evangelicals
in the 1520s and
never went away.
Instead of becoming a shared
basis for reforming the church,
the Bible became a battleground
among Protestants as well
as between Protestants
and Catholics.
The church became the churches.
This, too, has never gone away,
despite all the ecumenical
efforts and advances
of the past half-century.
The Reformation was not an
initially coherent movement
that only later fragmented.
It prompted conflicting
claims about God's word
and God's will right
from the start.
It spread like wildfire
in the early 1520s
through printed pamphlets,
and salacious woodcut images,
and popular songs,
and word of mouth
in the Holy Roman
Empire and Switzerland.
In the mid-1520s, it inspired
mass uprisings across much
of central Europe in the
so-called German Peasants' War.
Princes and their mercenary
armies put a swift end to that,
whether they were
supporters or enemies of Rome.
Wherever the Reformation
flourished after 1525,
it would be contained
by political authorities
and controlled under
their watchful eye.
The decade after
the edict of Worms
in 1521 critically influenced
the subsequent history
of Protestantism.
Basic patterns were
established that would endure,
and few were more important than
the difference between forms
of the Reformation that received
sustained political support
and forms that did not.
A few words, then,
about each of these.
Two expressions of the
Reformation, Lutheranism
and reform Protestantism,
were backed by civic
or princely authorities.
Despite condemnation
from Charles the Fifth
and other Catholic leaders,
the patchwork character
of the Holy Roman Empire
enabled them to take root.
Starting in the 1520s, these
magisterial Protestants,
a term that refers to Lutherans
and reform Protestants
taken together,
began to create institutions,
forms of worship,
statements of faith, and
new ways of being Christian.
These measures were implemented
by political authorities
working together with clergy,
many of them, at first,
former Catholic priests
from the new Protestant
churches.
They agreed with the medieval
view that subjects had
to share the same religious
beliefs and practices,
just many different
ones from Catholics.
To make religion a matter
of individual choice
invited conflict and loss
of the shared basis for
life as a social, political,
and religious community.
All the other expressions
of the Reformation,
of which there were many
more than two, were outlawed.
Their members were punished
by political authorities,
whether Lutheran, reform
Protestant, or Catholic.
Lacking political patronage,
these radical Protestants,
as they're collectively
known, were often persecuted,
so their numbers remained
small until centuries later,
yet from the start,
they demonstrated
that God's word could
be and was understood
in many different
ways among those
who rejected the Roman
church, and they're essential
to understanding the
Reformation as a whole
and its abiding importance
down to the present.
They make clear the Reformation
cannot be reduced to Luther's
or any other reformer's
theology or biography.
Think of Martin Luther and the
unlikely events of 1517 to 1521
like a stone plunked in a pond.
Then imagine the Reformation
in the 1520s and beyond
as ripples radiating outward
in all directions, everywhere,
disrupting the water's surface.
Those disruptions
were not restricted
to the Holy Roman Empire or
Switzerland, and so we move
on to act three, but first,
I need a real drink of water.
Act three is entitled,
"The Reformation
Defines a Troubled Era."
The spread of the Reformation
throughout Europe made it the
defining development of
an entire historical era,
not simply a German phenomenon
of regional significance.
Wherever it spread, rulers
had to decide how to respond,
like they had in
Germany and Switzerland
since the early 1520s,
including regions
where the Reformation
was harshly suppressed
and that remained strongly
Catholic, like Spain.
If all rulers had chosen
for the Reformation --
-- and in the same form,
the 16th century would
have been very different.
Instead, divergent
decisions led to divisions,
reflected disagreements,
and contributed to conflicts
that would prove
important to developments
that still influence us today.
Understanding the Reformation
and its long-term impact means
understanding the Reformation
era, including not only
the Protestant traditions
that formed but also
the relationships
between Protestants
and Catholics
as well as among Protestants.
Political authorities that opted
for the Reformation determined
whose Protestantism got
supported and whose got
suppressed in the 1520s.
The same was true throughout the
16th century and into the 17th.
Lutheranism and reform
Protestantism were the two forms
that survived and flourished.
Anglicanism -- I have
heard of it, just FYI.
Anglicanism is a particularly
case, and the term is not used
by scholars, at least
responsible scholars,
to describe the Protestantism
of the Church of England
until after 1660, so the period
of the Restoration later on,
but I just want to
allay any concerns that,
"Why isn't this Reformation
expert mentioning Anglicanism?
It's like dude, there is
such a thing as Anglicanism."
I know it.
Okay. Moving on.
Starting in the 1530s,
magistrates in Geneva worked
with the refugee
reformer John Calvin
to make their French-speaking
Swiss city into a stronghold
for his version of
reformed Protestantism.
It would have a major impact
in France, England, Scotland,
and the Netherlands
as well as in parts
of Germany and eastern Europe.
All other expressions
besides Lutheranism
and reform Protestantism,
including those espoused
by all the different
Anabaptist groups,
spiritualist Protestants,
and other radical Protestant,
were usually outlawed.
Mostly these Christians
wanted just to be left alone,
at least before the
1640s in England.
Catholicism was no less
dependent on the choices
of rulers who decided to
oppose the Reformation.
They helped foster a major
re-energizing of Catholicism
in the 16th century,
usually referred
to as the Catholic Reformation
or the Counter-Reformation.
Reforming efforts underway
in Christendom before
1517 were expanded
and new ones were taken up.
A major meeting of
Catholic church leaders,
the Council of Trent,
convened on and off three times
between 1545 and 1563.
The Reformation era was
thus marked by the renewal
of Roman Catholicism no
less than by the creation
of magisterial and radical
Protestant traditions.
Magisterial Protestants
and Catholics undertook some
initiatives in parallel tracks.
In other ways, they were locked
in competitive opposition
and mutual hostility.
Both of these are key
for understanding the
Reformation era's influences
down to the present, so I'll
say a bit about each one.
Whether Lutheran, reform
Protestant, or Catholic,
political authorities
and clergy sought
to channel constructive
creative religious commitments
into action.
Well-trained clergy preached
sermons and taught catechisms,
reconciled feuds and encouraged
devotion, praised piety
and excoriated sin,
consoled the grieving
and comforted the dying.
They were all trying to create
well-informed communities
of dedicated lay Lutherans,
reform Protestants,
or Catholics, respectively.
This wasn't a smooth or uniform
process, and they didn't succeed
across the board or as
well as they wanted to,
yet the net result was
that European countries forged
the dominant state-supported
religious identities of their
subjects in the Reformation era
and carried them into
the modern world.
Lutheran Denmark, Sweden,
and much of Germany;
reform Protestant
Scotland, England, sort of,
the Netherlands, and parts of
Switzerland; Catholic Spain,
Italy, France, Austria,
Ireland, Poland, Belgium,
and parts of Germany
and Switzerland.
Not all the laity
appreciated these efforts.
Some complied, but resented
conscientious clergy
as obnoxious and intrusive.
Others rolled their
eyes, dragged their feet,
and did as little as
they could get away with,
not that that has anything
to do with anybody who sat
through a bad Sunday
school class in their life.
Still others dissented
and pursued radical
Protestant alternatives.
This resentment, as a byproduct
of sometimes heavy-handed
methods of indoctrination
and attempts to control
lay behavior,
would have repercussions.
It would eventually
help inspire initiatives
of liberation very
different from those of Luther
or other early evangelicals.
These parallel efforts
to create communities
of well-informed Christians
coexisted with disagreements
about God's truth and
concrete hostilities
between rival Christian regimes.
The Reformation made the
religion at Christendom's heart
into a series of major
problems because religion was
so interconnected
with the rest of life.
As in the Middle
Ages, it was assumed
that religion should shape
politics and society no less
than worship and piety.
The period's doctrinal
controversies began
with Luther's first criticisms
of many Catholic teachings.
They also ripped apart the
early evangelical movement.
They continued and
were institutionalized
as the 16th century unfolded.
Doctrinal controversy became
an ongoing, permanent feature
of the Reformation era.
The leading protagonist of
these controversies were mostly
university-trained theologians,
but similar views
were also expressed
in polemical propaganda,
pamphlets, sermons,
songs that denounced papists
or heretics respectively.
By the 1650s, theological
experts were as far apart
as in the 1520s, marshalling
their often formidable learning
to buttress their
respective positions.
Ditto for lay Catholics
and Protestants,
though in many parts of
Europe, however grudgingly,
they were starting to
forge various means
of day-to-day coexistence.
Not wanting to compromise
was understandable.
Divisive disagreements
about doctrine were deepened
by the so-called
Wars of Religion,
which we really should call
the wars of more than religion,
because religion was about
so much more than religion
as we usually think of it.
These conflicts included
the German Peasants' War
of the mid-1520s,
the Schmalkaldic War
in the Holy Roman Empire,
1546 to '47, the French Wars
of Religion from 1562 to 1598,
the Dutch revolt against Spain
that started in 1566
and lasted until 1648,
the Thirty Years' War
from 1618 to 1648,
and the English revolution
of the 1640s and 50s.
These religiopolitical
conflicts were expensive,
destructive, and inconclusive.
They brought widespread death,
disease, and dislocation.
They caused suffering
and bitterness.
They created thousands
of religious refugees.
The Reformation era was both
constructive and destructive.
Distinct churches,
religious traditions,
and Christian identities were
forged and carried forward
into the modern era, and they
were protected and promoted
by political regimes
whose mutual conflicts,
like their doctrinal
disagreements,
made Christian truth
into a civilizational
bone of contention.
The Reformation period
was an area
of extraordinary
religious vitality.
It extended and deepened
the medieval assumption
that Christianity should
influence and infuse all areas
of human life because
it expressed God's will
for human beings, so of course,
religion should be about more
than just beliefs,
worship, and devotion.
It should also inform
the exercise of power,
social relationships,
economic transactions,
and higher education,
and in order
to do this, it had to be shared.
It had to be collective,
not merely individual.
Yet this widely shared
assumption was precisely what
made Christianity such a major
problem in the Reformation era.
When people agree that religion
should be the foundation
of their civilization but they
can't agree about its content,
they're in for trouble.
That's why sustained
disagreement is the most
decisive basic fact about
the Reformation era,
painfully tragic as it is
for ecumenically
minded Christians today.
Christendom's foundation had
become its central problem,
so it fractured violently.
The disruptiveness
of and resistance
to the Reformation were evident
already in the early 1520s.
In many different,
prolonged, and convoluted ways,
they played out across
the European continent
for over a century.
By the mid-17th century, a new
sort of creativity was needed
if an exhausted continent was
to avoid a fratricidal future.
What do you do when the source
of your world view, values,
and framework of meaning is
also the source of recurrent,
large-scale violence and an
insuperable impasse of ideas.
Maybe you try to find a
different source of meaning
and some new ideas, and you
do what you can to restrain
and redefine the source
that created the problems.
That's what those
espousing new ideas
and institutions started
doing in the mid-17th century,
and so we move on to act
four, Modernity as a Response
to the Reformation era.
The Reformation --
-- was a religious
revolution that led
to the secularization
of society.
Major paradox.
It's not what Luther
or any other Protestant
reformers wanted,
but you're in a position now
to understand how it happened.
The Reformation made the
religion of Latin Christendom
into an unprecedented
problem rooted
in doctrinal disagreements
and manifest in more
than religious conflicts.
The problem had to be addressed.
How could Christians who
believed contrary things
about fundamental
aspects of human life
on which they believed eternal
salvation depended coexist
in relative peace and stability?
It's often harder to discern
history's gradual processes
than its discrete events.
This goes for the unintended
processes of secularization
that have followed from
the Reformation era.
We have to take a
perspective on change over time
across centuries in
order to see them.
They did not emerge quickly
or win the day suddenly
in the 17th century,
or even in the 19th.
Religious has been and remains,
of course, a constant presence
in Europe and North America
throughout the modern era
to our own day.
Here, then, secularization
does not mean the disappearance
or the elimination of religion.
It doesn't mean merely a decline
in how many people
attend worship, or pray,
or say they believe in God.
It refers rather to the
declining influence of religion
in shared public life, all
those areas of human life
that in the Middle Ages and the
Reformation era Christianity was
supposed to inform: politics,
law, economics, education,
social relationships, family
life, morality, and culture.
Western modernity has everything
to do with the management
and control of religion
because in the Reformation era,
Christianity itself
became such a problem.
The disagreements mattered
so much because religion was
about so much more
than religion,
with eternal ramifications
to boot,
so when the disagreements gained
social and political traction
and grew beyond a certain point,
as they did in the Holy Roman
Empire, France, England,
and the low countries, the
results were cataclysmic.
The basic solution to the
problem, then, and the core
of the piecemeal processes
of secularization central
to western modernity
meant finding ways
to make whatever was
disruptive and divisive
about religion matter
less for public life.
Christian controversies
and conflicts threatened
coexistence.
For centuries, Christianity had
been embedded in and intended
to influence everything,
so its problematic features
should be disembedded
from everything.
What would that entail?
In order for it to be separated
from politics, economics,
and social relationships,
religion had to be conceived
as something separable
from them.
Seen the other way around,
politics, economics,
and social relationships had
to be conceived as things
that could and should
operate apart from religion.
So religion itself had to
be redefined along the lines
of what we usually
mean by religion,
your own interior beliefs,
worship preferences,
and chosen devotional practices.
Those were fine, because
they didn't aspire
to influence anything that was
supposed to apply to everyone.
Note your beliefs,
preferences, and choices.
That is crucial.
The modern redefinition
of religion meant making
it an individual choice.
Individual religious
freedom was made possible
because religion was redefined
and its scope restricted.
Individuals, sometimes
within the same families,
disagreed about religion
in the Reformation era,
so religious freedom
would have to be protected
at the individual level.
This was a dramatic change
from sharing religious beliefs
and practices that applied to
everyone, a democratization
of Luther's "here I stand" in
a way he would have deplored,
as is clear from his harsh
polemics against those
who disagreed with him.
Whatever its content, religion
could be tolerated so long
as everyone who benefited
from religious freedom agreed
on limiting its scope in
the same ways and agreed
to obey the political
authorities that extended
and protected that freedom.
The restriction and redefinition
of religion opened the way
to secularization
through separation,
although in practice,
that detachment has been
and remains a very
complicated process
that has been unfolding
over centuries.
Secularization as an ongoing
process has also had a long-term
intellectual dimension.
It's no accident that
the Enlightenment
and modern philosophy
started in the 17th century.
Christian ideas about
reality, human nature,
and human life provided
Christendom's intellectual
backbone during the Middle Ages.
During the Reformation era,
that backbone was broken.
Theological controversy
that started
in the 1520s remained
unresolved in the 1650s,
after the Thirty Years' War
and the English revolution.
How could entrenched
religious opponents agree
about human nature, morality,
government, and other issues
at once fundamental
and divisive?
They'd have to agree
to disagree.
They'd have to bracket
their religious views
when they embarked
on common endeavors.
Theology would have to be
separated from philosophy
and the investigation
of the natural world,
neither of which could depend on
anything divisively religious.
New ways of trying
to ground morality,
justify political authority, and
conceive society were sought.
Descriptions of and
prescriptions
for human life would have
to avoid explicit reference
to religion if they
hoped to persuade people
who disagreed about it.
If you didn't want to just
keep preaching to choir,
you had to learn how to
sing a different song.
Ideas and institutions central
to modern liberal democracies
are interrelated aspects
of the ways that western
modernity has addressed problems
inherited from the
Reformation era
as a reaction, not
as an outgrowth.
These include individual
freedom and autonomy,
freedom of religion, religious
toleration, the separation
of church and state,
secular public discourse,
the secularization of
knowledge, and the pursuit
of human fulfilment
through material well-being.
Just like the beginning of
the Reformation in Wittenberg,
the process of addressing the
Reformation era's problems
in a new way started
in an unlikely place,
in a strange little
republic at war
with Europe's most
powerful monarchy,
from which it had just
declared its independence.
In the 1580s, no one in their
right mind would have bet
on the Dutch republic in
revolt against mighty Spain
and its empire, yet the
magistrates and the merchants,
especially of Holland's cities,
hit on something important.
They decided to de-emphasize
religious uniformity
and to go shopping instead,
and that's what we're
still doing, for real.
Holland's urban leaders combined
limited religious toleration
with a seaborne trading
empire in what turned
out to be the wave
of the future.
They hit on a new relationship
among religion, politics,
and economics that would
eventually change the world,
sowing secularizing seeds of
modernity in the tough soil
of the Reformation era.
Much else would fertilize it,
including Enlightenment ideas,
but they got the
process started.
Europeans in other
countries noticed.
The British in particular
imitated the Dutch
and integrated what they learned
into their own much
more powerful empire
in the later 17th
and 18th centuries.
It turned out that religious
toleration was good for business
so long as the scope of religion
was restricted and didn't,
heaven forbid, seek to inhibit
entrepreneurial initiative
or to curtail expansionist
political ambition.
What the Dutch started
was extended
and first institutionalized
in other odd republic at war
with that British empire,
the United States of America.
It combined the federal
disestablishment of churches
with individual religious
freedom and no proscriptions
about how citizens should act
on their newly protected rights
to life, liberty, and
the pursuit of happiness.
A narrow Dutch notion
of religion persisted.
American citizens could
believe as they pleased
and worship as they wished.
At the same place,
whether rich or poor,
Americans exercised
their religious freedom
as they pursued more and
better material possessions,
just like the Dutch and
the British before them.
The advent of the Industrial
Revolution that coincided
with the creation of the new
nation enabled many more people
to acquire many more
possessions much more cheaply.
Industrialization in the 19th
century solidified this trend
in the US as well as in
western European countries,
some sooner than others.
It gave everyone something
besides religion to care about
and to devote themselves to.
The most recent expressions
of secularization borne
of the relationship
among religion, politics,
and economics, have been visible
in the last several decades
on both sides of
the north Atlantic.
Religion's influence
has diminished
as material affluence
has soared.
Religion has ceased
to have much, if any,
capacity to influence
society in shared public ways.
Religious pluralism enabled
by religious freedom means
that when religious citizens --
-- do enter the public arena,
their participation mirrors
a secularized and, in the US,
deeply divided public
political culture.
One could hardly ask for a more
spectacular expression of this
than what emerged starting with
our most recent election cycle.
Christianity has little capacity
to influence the wider society
in any collective way because
Christians themselves are
divided on every
contentious political, social,
and moral issue, including
abortion, same-sex marriage,
gun control, immigration,
international interventions
abroad,
and the current occupant
of the White House.
Democratic states today protect
an ever-increasing diversity
of beliefs, priorities,
and practices.
A nearly universal participation
in consumerism capitalism
plus political control
by those states served to hold
western societies together,
or at least seemed to
relatively well until Brexit
and then the 2016
American election showed
that there were political
costs to four decades
of economic neoliberalism,
but these long-term outcomes
of attempts to solve
the problems inherited
from the Reformation era have
unintentionally created new
problems of their own, for
example, global climate change,
a byproduct of the industrial
processes that manufacture all
that stuff that politically
protected consumers want
in exercising their rights.
Long-term processes
of secularization have been
an attempt to control religion
and to resolve the
difficulties that followed
in the wake of the Reformation.
They're not an extension or
fulfilment of the Lutheranism
or the reform Protestantism
of the Reformation era.
Choosing your own beliefs
and values, whether religious
or not, and buying
as much as you want
of whatever you want are
worlds away from the freedom
of a Christian espoused
by Luther,
and when we see what modern
freedom can mean in practice,
in terms of choosing to believe
and support whatever you prefer,
as, for example, in our most
recent presidential election,
we get some sense of just how
far-reaching have been the
modern institutional and
ideological endeavors to deal
with the problems inherited
from the Reformation era.
So in brief and by
way of conclusion,
that's why the Reformation
still matters,
whether we like it or not.
It unintentionally
and indirectly created
the world we inhabit,
regardless of what we
believe or care about,
by making Christianity itself
into an enduring problem
that had to be addressed.
The way it was addressed
redefined religion
and made it separable
from the rest of life,
and now increasingly,
we see evidence of what
that separation looks like,
and we will, I'm sure,
continue to see evidence of it
facilitated by the combination
of politically protected
individual preferences,
technological wizardry, and
the power of money distributed
with radical inequality,
some expressions
of which we probably
can't imagine
and which will probably
be as unexpected
as were the eventual
consequences
of the Reformation
500 years ago.
So whatever one makes of
our current situation,
and thinks we ought to do, and
whatever scale of engagement
or action, it seems to
me we're well advised
to acknowledge the
character of that situation
and how we got to where we are.
It presents challenges
to all of us,
regardless of what we
believe and regardless
of the specific geographical,
institutional,
and social locations we inhabit.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So my understanding is now that
there's time for some questions,
so long as they're
easy, softball questions
and benign in every respect.
I'm being facetious, of course.
Sir in the front here.
>> This is a question about the
great man theorem of history.
I mean there were popular
reformers [inaudible] and 15th,
16th century, and there was, of
course, Erasmus and [inaudible].
He was admired by Luther.
Erasmus was an intellectual.
I don't think he was -- I don't
think he really had much popular
appeal, but what about if
there hadn't been some guy
like Luther, as forceful,
as charismatic,
as belligerent in
his viewpoints?
Would the Reformation
have occurred?
>> Brad Gregory:
Yeah, so this is one
of those giant what historians
call counterfactual questions.
If it hadn't been
for Luther, right,
then what would have happened?
One of the difficulties of
trying to answer a question
like this about a
phenomenon that, if even half
of what I've argued tonight
is right, the Reformation was
so dramatically transformative,
it's hard to imagine
if it hadn't happened, well,
how might things have
transpired differently.
So that's the dodge aspect of
my answer to your question.
I think -- well,
there's certainly --
there are all kinds
of reform initiatives
and so forth underway
prior to Martin Luther.
This has been one of the really
important, I think, developments
in scholarship on
the late Middle Ages
and the early 16th
century in recent decades.
You mention Erasmus, and I mean
I think it's very interesting,
because Erasmian humanism
and Erasmus' vision
for the gradual reform
of Christendom is very
different from Luther's.
It's based primarily
on patient education.
Humanist scholars, no
surprise, are the heroes.
They're the ones who
have the languages
and are doing the philological
and the scholarly research
that's going to go back
to the sources, as
they say, ad fontes,
and by producing reliable
editions of the scriptures,
as Erasmus himself
did -- well, reliable.
Not by the criteria of
contemporary biblical scholars,
but very much so at the time.
His edition of the 1516 New
Testament with facing text,
Latin and Greek is incredibly
important, but the question is:
You know, what might Erasmian
humanism have achieved had,
you know, there not
been someone, again,
as sort of insistent
and, as you said,
belligerent as Martin Luther?
There certainly are other
reformers who reject Rome
in the course of the 1520s
who have personalities very
different from Martin Luther.
Huldrych Zwingli can be nasty,
but nothing like Luther.
And so I think, you know, in
the end, we're left with sort
of speculative, interesting
discussion, fun discussion
to talk about over a beer, but
I think it's really impossible
to resolve in any kind of
compelling or kind of, you know,
universally persuasive way what
might have transpired instead
without -- major historical
counterfactuals, I think,
simply have that character.
Thanks. Yes, sir?
>> I'm just curious.
I would like to hear
your thoughts
about the second large religion,
Islam, which has had this schism
between the Sunni and the
Shiite for centuries, for much,
much longer than the
Catholicism and Martin Luther,
which after a couple of
hundreds years of vicious wars,
Thirty Years' War, other wars,
came to an understanding and led
to the religious freedom
which you espoused here.
What do you foresee, if
anything, in speculations?
Is there a possibility between
the Sunni and the Shiite,
which have been fighting each
other for over a thousand years,
well over a thousand
years, that they would come
to an accommodation at
any time in the future
like there has been development
in the Christian world?
>> Brad Gregory: Well, I have
a dodge on this question, too.
The question is prospects for
the relationship between Sunni
and Shia Muslims in
terms of reconciliation
in the future analogous
to that, the kind of ways
of accommodating
coexistence that Protestants
and Catholics have to
large extent achieved
in the modern world in the west.
My dodge on this is I'm
not a scholar of Islam.
I really am not, so
I'm not -- the other --
it's fascinating to me.
One, I get a counterfactual
question
about if Luther hadn't
come along,
how might everything have
been different in the past,
and now I get a question about,
you know, what do you foresee
in the future about the
relationship between --
you know, I'm just
a humble historian.
I try to study what actually
happened and how it played out.
That said, I mean, well, the
relationship of different groups
within Islam, including, most
importantly, Sunni and Shia,
but they're not the only
ones, is, of course,
one important dimension of the
kinds of conflicts and unrest
that we see in not
only the Middle East,
other parts of the
world, and so forth.
Another critically
important part is the ways
in which western powers
intervened in the Middle East
in the late 19th and
early 20th centuries
and arbitrarily divided up,
sliced and diced different
countries, and so forth,
and created problems because
of the borders that they drew
in ways that were
not there before.
So many of the problems
that we see
in the Islamic world today are
at least difficult to extricate
from the western
interventions of the last,
say, century and a half.
Another crucially important
question, and one I think
that many westerners
are at least
as concerned with, is about --
-- the ways in which Muslims,
whether Sunni, or Shia,
or from some other group,
are likely to, able to,
or willing to make the
sort of accommodation
that most liberal westerners
hope that they will make,
and that, it seems to me,
is maybe even a more
pressing question than the one
about the relationship
between Sunni and Shia.
I'll make just one sort
of side comment on that.
It seems to me, and I say
this partly from my reading
and also partly from talking
to some Muslim friends,
they look at certain aspects
of western society and see it
as a negative lesson in what
they don't want to happen
to their own societies
and the ways in which --
when I talk about religion
as more than religion here
in the early 16th century,
religion is more than religion
in Muslim societies today, too,
even ones that are relatively
liberal, to say nothing
of the ones that have the kind
of tightest interwoven aspect
of Islam with all dimensions
of life, and when they look
at the west, for example,
and they say, "Yeah,
you say it's awful what
we do to our women,
but look at the widespread
pornography on every available,
right, downloadable laptop
everywhere in the western world.
Which one of those
is worse, you know?"
I've had Muslim friends
say things like that to me.
So the only point being I don't
think it's a simple problem,
and I don't think that all
the aces are held by the west.
Yes, in the back.
>> If religion and Christianity
-- before the Reformation,
I would say that it
held us together.
It was like a skeleton
or a basis
on which people were informed as
to how to behave, how to live,
how to do business,
interact with each other,
not just what to believe, right.
>> Brad Gregory: Yeah,
about practice as much --
in fact, practice even
more, in some ways,
than explicit beliefs.
>> Well, now, recently, I
spent 11 years living in India
with Tibetan refugees,
and they, too, live --
they live their religion.
It informs everything --
>> Brad Gregory: Right.
>> -- they do, and I
see when they leave,
because many are trying
to leave, when they come
to the west and they no longer
live in that society, they, too,
like us -- I mean it was the
glue that held them together
and held their culture together.
Well, what you have just
described is we are all
drifting apart.
We're drifting further and
further away from anything
that we can all recognize
and value,
and if that is the case --
and I have another example
as a retired schoolteacher.
I see that in our schools.
Our schools no longer teach
the basic, classical education.
They just don't, and so
now, I was just talking
to an intern today, and he
said, "Nowadays in school,
kids just focus on what
kind of job they want.
That's what they're focused on."
So let's say somebody wants
to be a mathematician,
so they study math.
They don't know anything else,
so who do they relate to?
Who can they relate to?
>> Brad Gregory: Yeah.
>> Another mathematician,
you know, but not the rest
of the world, so
even our own society,
as you're suggesting,
is drifting apart.
There's nothing to hold
us together anymore,
and if there is, please
tell us what it is.
>> Brad Gregory: Hey, you
know, you're preaching
to the choir on that one.
I mean that's very close to
my analysis of the situation
in which we find ourselves.
I published a book
several years ago --
Nicholas mentioned it
in his introduction --
called The Unintended
Reformation,
in which I said some things
about the kind of divisiveness
and the dividedness of
particularly Americans,
but we can see it also
in different guises
in western European
countries as well.
That was published in 2012, and
it was really interesting to me.
During the course of the
election, before November
of 2016, I got a number
of emails from readers
of that book saying, "So I mean
it's scary how spot-on you were,
you know, about this," because
there was an important debate
among observers and
analysts in the United States
in recent years about, you know,
"Is there really culture
wars in the United States?
Oh, it's just some
small, vocal minorities.
Really, most Americans agree and
can get along with one another,"
and I think -- I mean now, we'd
be hard pressed to find anybody,
I think, who would
defend the view
that it's not really
deeply divided.
The question then, of
course, is, you know,
really, where do we turn?
What are the, you know, possible
alternatives for something
that could, you know, function?
What's deeply troubling
to me and many others --
again, I'm not saying
anything that probably all
of you haven't heard ad nauseam
in the last year in
terms of analysis.
What's particularly disturbing
is what I would call a crisis
of shared epistemology.
By that I mean we don't even
agree on what the sources
of our information
are to be able
to have a shared discussion,
so the determination
of what is the case, the facts,
are, well, you know, "No,
I'll get mine from Breitbart.
You get yours from MSNBC."
You know, it's impossible
to have a shared discussion
if you don't agree substantially
on what the [inaudible] are.
I don't have an answer to that.
Again, this is amazing.
It's like how would
you speculate
that the past would have
been utterly different
without Luther, what do
you think's going to happen
to Muslims in the future,
and please give us the answer
to our incredibly
divided problems.
No problem.
That's what historians
are trained to do.
So anyway, maybe we have
time for one more question.
Yeah, sir, in the back?
>> It may be a question,
may be more of a comment.
You talked about basically how
after the Thirty Years' War,
things started to -- the
church basically went
to a very scholastic place,
but I think there was
still a cultural divide
between the intellectual,
philosophical part of the church
and the pietistic movement in
Europe that eventually came here
in this country that brought us
the two Great Awakenings a very
conservative religious
movement that continues,
possibly through the Charismatic
movement, to this day,
where the church itself has
divided again, in a certain way.
Could you comment about that?
>> Brad Gregory: Well, I mean
there really never is a point
from even the early
decades of the Reformation
in the 16th century
when Protestantism seen
as a whole doesn't
encompass an enormous variety
of different movements,
churches, organizations,
and so forth, so yes, of
course, I mean in terms
of whether we're talking about
an anglophone context and, say,
talking about Methodism and
John Wesley in the 18th century
as a kind of intra-Anglican
pietistic movement, say,
that's parallel to what's going
on in German-speaking
territories with respect
to Lutheranism, because pietism,
the usual meaning of pietism
that starts in the
early 17th century,
with people like
Arndt and others.
Those are absolutely part of,
would fit into what I was
talking when I'm talking
about the constructive
aspects, right,
of the religious traditions that
come out of the Reformation era,
not only the various Protestant
traditions, but also Catholicism
that will develop and continue
to the present day as well.
So yes, that is absolutely
part of the story.
It fits into the picture
that I've described here,
because once we get
into the modern world,
you can be a pietist,
you can be a Unitarian,
you can be a Quaker,
you can be a Catholic,
you can be a Charismatic,
you can be whatever you
want to be, you know.
The point is you can be
whatever you want to.
Religious freedom is politically
protected, but you know,
we're not going to share any
of that, right, in common.
It's not going to be proscribed.
You can believe whatever
you want
so long as you obey the laws.
That's the basic way in which
the problem of Christianity
from the Reformation era
is attempted to be solved.
For most of US history,
for a long time,
certainly when Tocqueville
visits in the early 1830s,
he looks, and he
sees, "Incredible.
Look at this.
All these different
Protestant groups.
Even got a smattering of
Catholics and so forth,
even a handful of Jews, right."
He says, "All the
Christian groups, right,
they all worship God
in different ways,
yet they all share
the same morality.
They all share a sense of
duty, and of public mindedness,
and what it is that
people owe to one another."
That's what's gone.
That's what dissipated, and I
think in ways that are parallel
to the decline of the so-called
mainstream Protestant churches
in the United States, because
they were the cultural backbone
of that phenomenon.
So that's a situation
in which it seems
to me we find ourselves,
but absolutely,
those Protestant traditions
that you're talking about,
that originated in Europe,
came across the Atlantic,
have definitely had an influence
here, as have the others.
So anyway, I could stay here all
night, but I probably shouldn't.
So thanks again to
everyone for coming.
I really appreciated it.
Great questions, and
have a good evening.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.